okay
no no no no you're in trouble a whole
new conversation into it so it's
our fault and we are we have no choice
in the matter of oh we have to protect
ourselves because men
can't control them i never said that i
know women are sexual i never said that
as your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zinna well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom that
relationship with your lord is
fundamental for you to survive
the faith the faith of faith gives you
not just faith um purpose yes it is it
is very much not fake i'm not saying to
you because anyone can have any religion
they can say oh yeah but i'm just saying
just faith
leads to hope hope leads to purpose
purpose gives you
life and
and you have you have some kind of
certainty because the fact that you say
i have these different religions and i
follow what like i take a bit that is
that is your kind of certainty though if
you think about it you've got a bit of
that i live by this room yeah so you've
given yourself a certainty but what
we're saying is maybe it's not the true
certainty yeah because what we're saying
is there should be one way of life
there's one truth you can't have two
truths there's only one god there can't
be two gods if there's two gods who
created that god there has to be one way
of life there has to be one truth
because if we come and say oh
i take a bit of this and a bit of that
etc it's genuinely it first it doesn't
make sense so i know this is like a
completely like a far-off perfect
question right for argument's sake let's
say the entire world is muslim yes do
you think that there would still be the
problems that we have now there will be
problems but not the problems that we
have now okay so there will still
so like what sort of issues would would
be posed if everyone had the same
religion and the same thoughts and the
same way of thinking we can't because
that's what allah says in the quran we
created you
by like tribes and nations that you
might get to know one another not that
you despise one another the point is
this allah's created us with a
to have decision free will yeah so we
have that's the reason why we have a
variety but the thing is there are also
consequences of the decisions that we
make so we can't just say okay i'm just
going to believe this if what we believe
is false there's going to be
consequences because god almighty has
created us and he wants the best for us
yeah he wants you to have the best of
this life in the hereafter he wants you
have to have a relationship with him and
be grateful to him yeah he's not asking
for much i'll be honest yeah so the
point is this and he's telling you to
leave him to live accept all the other
things that he also asked none of us but
he has a right to ask for them because
the thing is anything he asks for it's
not it's not bad for me it's good for me
like mention something that's bad like
you in islam like you say you know what
i don't know i don't like this okay oh
okay
why why why do i have to cover
okay
firstly because number one firstly
because god said so why do i have no
okay no but like so why
why is it that if i i'm not covered for
example
um i i i truly believe also that in
islam like if you are a true believer of
islam you also believe that for example
let's say i am a practicing muslim and
i'm not with hajj
i can still go to heaven a hundred
percent if you don't wear what a high
job yeah no one said no no one said you
go hell if you don't wear it by them i
know i know yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah that's why i say that wearing
a hijab is a choice right no it's not
choice
let me tell you something okay
so you're telling me it's not a choice
don't do it then i and i am a practicing
muslim i won't go to hell but it's not a
choice you will go where i'll go to hell
no you said that
so what no is there any prescribed
punishment for a woman that doesn't wear
hijab no but then why is it why is it
forced upon me if it's not
something that will lead me for example
so yeah so why is it something that is
not a choice so you don't have a choice
you have to cover but if you don't cover
and you are practicing good muslim that
does not mean you'll go to hell but you
have to cover why okay good question
have you read a book called beauty sick
no okay i want to buy this book if it's
possible beauty sick beauty sick yeah
that's why non-muslim
okay it's a very good book
yeah now this book is very interesting
because we have this false
notion
that
when a woman takes their hijab off she
chose to take it off i believe this is
the biggest false fallacy ever okay you
know why
because i'm asking you a question did
you choose to take your hijab off
i never had a hijab okay you never wore
it okay
are you telling me
that
as a woman
you choose not to wear the hijab yes
i say no and i'll prove it let me tell
you how are you telling me that the
beauty industry
the females around you the society that
you live in have no effect on you and
the way you are perceived and that has
no element on you that you may feel
because the book that i refer to called
beauty sick tells you about women who
are beauty sick their sickness is beauty
which is what
when someone comes to me and says i
choose to wear the hijab i'm like please
don't lie
you wear the hijab because allah told
you to and now somebody comes and says
well that's islam is oppressive and i
say well no hold on a second because the
very woman who wear mini skirt who go
get their
excuse me the breasts done their
backside done their hips done their nose
down can you imagine they smash their
nose you know you know they get smashed
and then reshaped this is very important
the point is this
are you telling me these people go and
say i choose to no you don't choose to
you do it because the beauty industry
the standards that the the society have
put a bar on you are trying to reach
those at the cost that you can even lose
your life there was a mexican brazilian
woman who died because she got implants
on her backside she died
but then then your argument is actually
null and void because the same way that
a woman will choose or has no choice to
wear hijab
but also does this these things to
herself and it's like oh that's not her
choice yes then where where did you meet
in the middle and where is the choice
this is where you meet in the middle the
point is this nobody has a choice
listen carefully but then why do you
have free will if you don't have a
choice the [ __ ] point
i'm sorry excuse me
so why
is has god okay so your your argument
here is telling me that god gives you
free will
and
allows you to have free will but you do
not have a choice okay
no listen to me carefully you have free
will
you have a choice in what sense which
one to follow so that so you're given
free will
just to choose god no no no listen let
me let me explain let me explain it let
me explain it
for example
both of them don't have no choice the
one who goes and gets a nose line and
has makeup and can't leave the house
without makeup being in front of the
window for two hours etc okay and the
woman who wears the hijab they are both
told to do so one is told to do so by
the one you created
thank you now now one second this is
where it's crucial
which one is deserving of being listened
to the one who created you or society
i mean if you believe not believe if
arguments say if god exists and he's
telling you and by the way we as many to
cover up as well i mean yeah but that's
a that's a theoretical question that
you're asking me because how like
who is more deserving of being obedient
to i mean if if that is your argument
then of course it's your creator that's
okay good obedience
so what we learned here today both
individuals have no choice they are both
told to do something okay one is from
the creator one is from the creation
this is where i accepted islam because i
said hold on a second and i'll give you
this personal story i used to have a
jumper like this there's a black one
i thought i looked really handsome in it
no i genuinely felt look you know i look
very good in this jumper i mean i mean i
think i look very good maybe some people
might differ
and i used to hate the jumper it used to
make me itch when i used to be in the
club i used to itch bob i just hated it
but i was like no i look good yeah
i said to myself you know what i'm the
biggest slave this is my master this
jumper is my master it's like girls who
walk into clubs with this much heels and
they have to take you off in winter and
it's freezing cold have you ever stood
on pavement
rather when i look at them i feel the
pain
i feel the pain and the thing is i'm
like that is your slave and just as me
when i was getting a jumper or driving a
certain car or going to the gym i'm not
saying you can go through the difficulty
saying you'd rather be a slave so the
one who created me
you know what you know my sister because
the creation is never going to happen
with me when i die they're going to back
bite me they're going to talk bad of me
the creator is the one that's going to
be be with me he's the one who created
me he deserves my worship why would i go
and try to please a group of people but
i'm never going to be happy with me and
the one who created me deserves it and
guess what once i became a slave to him
is when i found my true freedom
once i became a slave to him very good
honestly sister you the point i'm trying
to say here is this yeah thank you man i
bless you thank you i appreciate it
and this is the key sister you know why
because at this moment that is when it
clicked me and i said wow all this life
my masters were females my masters was a
jumper that i used to wear my masters
was money i used to live a lifestyle and
do extra hours so i can drive a certain
car i used to go to the gym yes
obviously for health reasons but i
wanted to have a big bicep so when i
walk and wear that jumper the girls can
be like wow look at his biceps i used to
live this was my these were my masters
these were my gods you know what i said
when i said
i said i am free from all of you
because i want to worship the one who
has created me and this is where we say
sister when we talked about
choice the one that takes a hijab we
have a lot of hijab influences who take
the java and they go um i chose to no
you didn't you gain older and you look
you feel like you're getting wrinkly and
ugly and you're showing the hair is
beauty and that is the reason why you
talk don't say i chose to say
i was forced to but then there's like so
in terms of like the
the not having a choice there for
something like that um like for example
it then comes down to equality again
which literally just circles us all the
way back but at one point yes yes
no no coming up
you know what you're talking can we have
your voice yeah you know when you're
talking about choice
you know you don't have a choice whether
to wear clothes or not do you in a
society
yeah you don't no so there's a certain
level of dressing decorum regardless of
however liberal you are you cannot come
naked you have to wear a trick this is
imposed upon you right
yeah
similarly
you should not equate
someone
putting on clothes
to somebody
because sometimes we go into this
mentality where we think the life i'm
living i'm free you're not you're
influenced one way or another because
why as a woman for example the question
is
and this is what's so beautiful about
islam let me tell you something before i
used to see woman as a piece of me
while i had no respect for them you know
why because this society made me like
this and when i came to islam woman they
became human in my eyes because islam
told me that you honor them you respect
them
it's not what is she you know you're
talking to her you're not talking to
someone else
and this is the issue sister there's
there's men here like there's men
everywhere the point is this and i'm not
saying women are perfect there are you
know a lot of you know
women as well
let's be honest here the point is this
that women are sexualized man i'm
walking down i'm driving down the a406
okay okay
no no no no you're bringing in trouble
all new conversation into it so it's our
fault and we are we have no choice in
the matter of oh we have to protect
ourselves because men
can't control them i never said that i
know women are sexual i never said that
i never said that did i say that no in
our sexual life no why are we sexualized
because the brain of men's can't
separate it from it
what does allah say in the quran you
know allah says in the quran i don't
know you tell me okay sister i'm not the
expert i'm gonna know nobody yo i think
you you know
we're about to explain
allah says in the quran tell the
believing men to lower their gays yeah
they should one second allah doesn't say
women cover up because men can't control
their self i know but why but then but
then why so if men shouldn't be gazing
and sexualizing and making all of this
yes then why do i yes
and and you have no choice but to also
cover up to protect myself
for what listen to me allah says to me
tell the believing man to lower the gaze
okay that means if she's in a bikini if
she's in a cup if she's in a gilbert
irrelevant after all my case i'm not
going to say oh she's wearing a bikini
man can look at her now oh oh she's
wearing a cup i have to lower my gaze
period
now
no no you know what that means that
means this notion that men can't control
their self that's why allah tells you to
cover up is not true because allah tells
who the believing men first tell the
believing mental over the gays
now allah allah does allah works in a
micro level you know what that means
you're training your young boys to
respect women by lowering the case yes
now how does allah deal with it in a
macro level
by saying do not sexually objectify
woman now if i am looking all around me
and i see bikini woman in there that's
talking about chocolate i'm not thinking
what's chocolate got to do with your
bikini yeah and then i'm seeing a woman
over there arguing saying dressed up in
this way and that way this society is
sexually objectifying woman look i was
watching a documentary yesterday yeah it
was talking about in the 1970s times
square in new york was a oh
it's disgusting there was a man who
killed 80 prostitutes
and these women were the they were not
human there was a study that was done
that looked into a man's brain they
showed him big women in bikini the part
of the brain that lights up foretold you
you know told you screwdriver lit up you
know what that means he didn't even see
him as human the power of the brain was
like this is this is an object how does
a human being and a lot of serial
killers you know they said something in
common they always watch pornography the
point is this
men are created visually if you sexually
objectify woman to such a level men lose
respect this doesn't mean that a person
has a right to go and abuse or rape or
whatever just because a woman is dressed
up in a certain way there are women who
are dressed up in hijab and the cub that
get raped the point is this sister
everyone has a role to play my role is i
lower my gates but i would not also like
you to this woman to be in my face or
dress up in a certain way where i'm like
well i wouldn't i would not like to see
that the point is this islam deals it
given the responsibility to both it
doesn't say hey you
men are animals you are to blame it's
your fault you cover up some doesn't say
that but the same way that women are
sexualized men can be sexualized as well
so then why are men when
are you sexual i'm sorry let me tell you
something yeah
let me tell you let me try to tell you
my sister yeah
do has i've never seen a woman ever go
and say you know what let me go and
there's a picture of a man's calves and
let me go and steroids
that's not a nature in her nature
men go and stare at women's coughs
bruh okay i don't know
sister cubs sister
that lose their mind
they lose their mind when they when they
see a toe
okay when they see your ankle he starts
his temperature starts rising his blood
pressure goes somewhere else
the way we're creating a system we are
visual so what i'm trying to say sister
is that allah is telling you this is the
best way to live your life and i'm
telling you sister look here there's a
lot of things i had to give up when i
came to istanbul a lot of things i did
not want to let go of but let me tell
you something
letting go of them it made me who i am
today
islam is the solution
there is no other religion i'm telling
you it might sound yeah okay here we go
my religion is i'm telling you we can
prove it i'm not here to talk i can
prove it islam gives me purpose i know
my purpose i know why i'm here i know
where i'm going i know what to live by
but the point is this islam is the best
solution and guess what you are going to
live by a way of life anyways and you
already are
live by the one that god sent you
because that's the best
you make very good points you make very
good points it's a very nice
conversation
oh my gosh i think it's been an hour
probably i think so too thank you sister
ali look thank you we don't shake hands
we don't yes but you know why but you
know why because it comes out of respect
but the thing is you see that oh i see
that's a little bit disrespectful ah
good but we need to end it with this you
know why because there was i think you
know the metoo movement remember the
meeting movement of course i know that
me too you know now in workplaces you
know back in the day not backing it like
a couple years ago in the workplace they
could touch a woman like you know they
can't do that anymore yeah you know in
the workplace they have to leave the
door open now yeah do you see islam has
come and told you look prevention is
better than islam has one solution it
doesn't say drink alcohol then we'll
take you to rehab islam says don't drink
alcohol
the point is this sister
me and you for example a handshake
is nothing like we can say okay what's
the big deal
but it's interesting that you see as a
sign of respect but to me i'm i feel
like i'm honoring you so much that i
don't even want to shake your hand not
because there's anything wrong with you
because you know why because that's the
level of respect i have for you but
society has made it seem as if you know
what look how disrespectful he is no i
don't think you're disrespectful it's
your it's your prerogative to not want
to shake my heart no no i do because i
honor and respect you well thank you
that's why i do it may allah bless you
you are a lovely person and it was it
was lovely talking to your sister if you
have any questions my table is there and
we can carry on inshallah and may allah
bless you inshallah and give us the best
in life
thank you